by saclay c'est un pour cent de la
population française 650 mille habitants
et 15% de la recherche publique
académique mais aussi 15 % la r&d
industrielle de la france donc c'est une
hyper concentration une très forte
spécialisation et pour la rendre
compréhensible parce que c'est au coeur
de ce qu'est le projet paris saclay avec
la constitution de l'université il nous
a paru intéressant de proposer une
lecture en cinq clusters industriels qui
sont je dirais par ordre d'apparition
aérospatiale défense sécurité mobilité
automobile
thijs et technologies de l'information
et la communication santé et énergie
climat avec un accent particulier sur la
gestion intelligente de l'énergie ce
qu'on appelle aussi les smart grid
mais les réseaux des changes de chaleur
et les technologies du bâtiment en
matière d'énergie également on a proposé
à trois industriels qui font partie de 3
des secteurs de nous rejoindre pour une
table ronde pendant tech'innove 2015 et
on a choisi le secteur de la santé dtic
et de l'énergie parce que ce sont trois
secteurs sur lequel aujourd'hui il ya
des enjeux très fort dans la compétition
mondiale entre clusters et écosystème
d'innovation
il nous a semblé particulièrement
intéressant de mettre en avant les
forces de paris saclay dans ces
différents domaines avec le témoignage
de sanofi pour le secteur à la santé
celui d'alcatel pour les technologies de
l'information et la communication et
d'alstom j
pour l'énergie
cette manifestation se déroule ici à
orly c'est de la 9e édition
l'intérêt c'est de réunir sur ce même
endroit
plus d'une centaine de grands comptes
d'honneur dans plus d'une centaine de
laboratoires qui permettent donc
d'accéder à ces pme leur permette
d'accéder à de la recherche et du
développement
une grande partie en fait du tissu de la
bo particuliers privés ou publics sont
situées sur le territoire de paris
saclay un gain bon nombre également de
start up se trouve sur les territoires
ddt europ'essonne la caps qui sont
générateurs à travers les liens qu'ils
ont avec les universités grandes écoles
générateur de projets porteurs de projet
intéressés par le fait de trouver ici
effectivement soit des sources de
financement soit des courants d'affaires
qui leur permettra de se développer